herzlich willkommen zu meinem Vortrag
Sozialkompetenz ohne Zeitdruck
vermitteln in präsenter virtueller und
hybrider Form ich danke dem Symposium
für die Einladung ja was möchte ich
heute erzählen ich möchte mich kurz
vorstellen wie ich Lehrende geworden bin
möchte meine Lehrveranstaltungen
präsentieren Beispiele aus der Praxis
geben und beenden mit einer
Zusammenfassung und einem Ausblick
kurz zu mir ja mein Motto warum bin ich
Lehrende geworden ja lebenslange Lernen
das ist mein Lebensmotto ich bin die
blumenkauffrau der LMU bei elf Jahre
Bereichsleiterin und habe mich dann
entschieden ja Dozentin zu werden seit
2019 bin ich lecture an der Universität
der Bundeswehr München habe mit
Unterstützung der Frau Dr Sabrina
Sontheimer das Abschlusszertifikat
Hochschullehre der bayerischen
Universitäten erfolgreich abschließen
können und werde dieses Jahr meine
Desertation abgeben
eine lehrbiografie ja die wurde geprägt
von Professor Lutz von Rosenstiel von
der LMU der dort lange Zeit
Organisationspsychologie gelernt hat und
der hat mir mitgegeben gut sing von
Jannis verhindern durch advokatos
diaboli Methode das heißt wenn sich alle
geeinigt haben wenn alle Studierenden
einer Meinung sind
dann mache ich den advokatos diaboli und
ja äh spiegele eine ganz andere Meinung
zu diesem Thema mit einem die Gruppe um
ja noch mal zu überlegen gemeinsam gibt
es nicht doch noch eine bessere Lösung
das andere was mich ja geprägt hat ist
dass johari-fenster von Luft und
klinghahn der blinde Fleck leichte kennt
der ein oder andere das blinder Fleck
ist das was mir unbekannt ist aber den
anderen bekannt ist und gerade ich lehre
Führung ja der Blinde flecht je höher
sie in der Hierarchie aufsteigen desto
größer wird ja naturgemäße
blutunterfleck weil sie kriegen kein
Feedback mehr und ich lehre die
Studierenden ganz praktisch sich
Feedback zu geben auch mir Feedback zu
geben
wertschätzendes Feedback zu geben damit
wir gemeinsam daran arbeiten diesen
blinden Fleck zu beseitigen damit wir
alle zusammen authentische
führungskräfte werden ja und dieses Jahr
die Fenster hat noch einen viertes
Fenster das mir persönlich sehr viel
wichtiger ist das unbewusst und das
Unbewusste dass es mir unbekannt das ist
den anderen unbekannt
und es ist ganz wichtig für die
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung sich dem
Unbekannten zu stellen weil nur dann
kann ich meine Persönlichkeit
weiterentwickeln nur dann kann ich
weiter wachsen und das ist ja man muss
versuchen aus seiner Komfortzone
herauszukommen sich dem Unbekannten
stellen und ja sich da bewähren
mein Lehrkonzept leer lerndreieck ich
als Lehrende habe die Philosophie erst
fordern dann fördern wie gesagt ich war
über zehn Jahre Bereichsleiterin ich
weiß in den ja Mitarbeitenden steckt
noch viel mehr in den Studierenden
steckt noch viel mehr Potenzial als sie
es erahnen erst fordern und dann fördern
der Inhalt meiner Lehrveranstaltung ist
geprägt vom Modulhandbuch das ist der
Bachelorstudiengang Management und
Medien an der Universität der Bundeswehr
und da heißt es im Modulhandbuch für die
Vorlesung Übung agea didaktisches Ziel
ist außerdem der Ausbau der sozialen
Kompetenzen die Studierenden sind im
zweiten Studienjahr die
ist eine Lehrveranstaltung im Harvey
Bereich das heißt ich habe Herrschaften
die kommen frisch vom Abitur die sind 18
19 aber ich habe auch Studierende
die sind auf dem zweiten Bildungsweg
haben die Fachabitur gemacht und die
können schon 30 plus dann sein
so die Blanche Taxonomie zu Orientierung
jeder von ihnen wird sie kennen ganz
unten steht das Erinnern und ja mir ist
es wichtig sehr weit in der blonischen
Taxonomie in meinen Lehrveranstaltungen
voranzukommen hier oben bei analysieren
beurteilen schaffen da fängt meines
Erachtens ja der wichtigste Teil einer
lernphilosophie an meine Lernziele sind
die soziale Kompetenz zu verbessern kann
man ratschaft Teamfähigkeit vernetztes
interdisziplinäres Denken Kritik wäre
ich Fähigkeit und ethisches Handeln das
heißt das was ich in den
Lehrveranstaltungen an input gebe darauf
bauen dann die Herrschaften auf und ja
entwickeln sich weiter mit meiner
Unterstützung stellen die richtigen
Fragen diskutieren miteinander und
hinterfragen wie gesagt advokatos
diaboli Methode hinterfragen dann auch
ja gefunden ist
so
ja das Setting meiner Herr Veranstaltung
hier begrüße ich einen
leadership-referenten
ich habe sowohl im Präsenzform gelehrt
als auch in
vollkommen
digitaler Form zu Zeiten Corona und ja
aktuell Lehre ich in hybrider Form
so zur Orientierung das sind meine Lehre
Evaluationen in diesem Modul
Vorlesung Übung HR über zwei Trimester
mit Ja zum Schluss 120 UE das heißt von
den Noten her es ist eine Fünfer Skala
dass die beste Note ist eine Eins sie
sehen hier von der Noten Entwicklung hat
es sich nicht geändert ob ich jetzt in
Präsenz gelehrt habe oder virtuell oder
dann eben Hybrid und ja das ähm sie
wissen dass wahrscheinlich selbst nicht
alle Studierenden nehmen leider an so
einer Evaluation Teil aber ja die ähm
wie soll man sagen das Feedback auf
meine Lehrveranstaltung ist sehr gut ich
habe jetzt hier eine Evaluation Stimme
zu virtuellen Lehre die ich vielleicht
kurz vorlese die Dozentin spricht aktiv
Studierende zum Mitarbeit innerhalb der
Online-Veranstaltung an und versucht
alles um die online-lehre unter und
lehrreich zu gestalten
nichtsdestotrotz ist online-lehre kein
qualitativer Ersatz für die präsenzle
das hat ein Studierender gesagt im
Herbst Trimester 2020
das war ein Trimester dass wir nur
virtuell angeboten haben
ja ich lehre nach der
Aviva Methode und lege da Wert auf einen
positiven Einstieg und einem positiven
Ausstieg sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen ich habe vier UE
hintereinander mit einer Pause das sind
also jeweils anderthalb Stunden eine
Pause insgesamt drei Stunden und ich bin
manchmal die zweite oder dritte
Dozierende die haben also ja 10 Stunden
quasi nacheinander Lehren das heißt mir
ist ganz wichtig wir steigen positiv ein
und wir steigen positiv auf
Ausrichtung es gibt immer einen
Fallbeispiel ja und dann frage ich das
Vorwissen ab
informiere macht den Stoff durch mit
meiner PowerPoint Präsentation Stelle
aber auch regelmäßig transferfragen weil
das wurde vorhin schon gesagt man merkt
dass die ähm dass sie Zuhörenden Zeit
brauchen das Wissen dann auch Sachen zu
lassen
und ich versuche zu jeder Lehreinheit
die ich habe praktische Beispiele dann
auch zu geben und auch nach praktischen
Beispielen zu fragen die haben sie
Führung erlebt wie würden Sie in dieser
Situation führen ja um das wie soll man
sagen um die Studierenden einzubinden es
interessanter zu machen und am Ende des
Tages sollen die keine Prüfung bestehen
sondern sollen sich im Leben bewähren
als potenzielle Führungskraft ja zu
Verarbeitung gebe ich dann im zweiten
Teil das ist dann die Übung anderthalb
Stunden gibt es Gruppenarbeiten
Präsentation Diskussion der Ergebnisse
im Plenum man muss auch in der Lage sein
Ergebnis vorzustellen sein Ergebnis zu
verteidigen sein Ergebnis zu begründen
und man muss auch ähm in der Lage sein
Feedback anzunehmen ja sich zu
verbessern das ist der blinde Fleck auf
den ich gerade schon zu sprechen kann ja
und zum Schluss machen wir eine Feedback
Runde um das eben dann abzuschließen
in Präsenzform wie habe ich da geleert
ich hatte ein prüfungsscript kein Lücken
eher Skript ich habe gelernt an der
Hochschule München man gibt auf gar
keinen Fall fertige Skripte raus sondern
da sind Lücken drin damit die
Studierenden kommen und diese Lücken
dann auffüllen bei mir ist es so dass
ich festgestellt habe dadurch dass ich
so viel Stoff machen darf ist der Stoff
einfach schon auf der Folie drauf der
Stoff so wie jetzt auch wird
portionsweise besprochen und sie müssen
sich nur noch aufschreiben was wichtig
ist sie müssen sich nur noch
aufschreiben die Beispiele die wir
gemacht haben
die Erkenntnisse gewonnen haben meine
Inhalte in diesem Powerpoints kann man
in einem Lehrbuch nachlesen das heißt
wenn jemand nicht da ist kann das nicht
kann das nachlesen wenn es jemanden zu
schnell war kann er nachlesen
ja wenn er mehr wissen will kann das
auch nachlesen und ich erkläre die
Schlüsselbegriffe und gibt einen
Überblick aber für die Prüfung braucht
man in seinem Studium das geht sonst
nicht
in Fallstudien werden die Gruppen gelöst
und sie kriegen dann von mir Feedback
was an was sie noch denken sollten ja
weil sie sich stehen natürlich im
Bachelor am Anfang und können ja noch
gar nicht alle Aspekte eines Themas dann
so professionell analysieren wie das
dann ja für die Praxis dann später
notwendig wäre sie präsentieren Lösungen
und da habe ich festgestellt dass sie
sich schwer tun Lösungen zu präsentieren
so zu präsentieren dass sie das Publikum
mitnehmen dass sie das Publikum
überzeugen dass es für die anderen auch
mehr wert hat aber wie gesagt deswegen
studieren sie ja dass sie das Lernen
in virtueller Form ja da ist es so dass
ich dann immer drei aufgerufen habe mit
Namen und Gruppenarbeit im Breakout
rumsangeboten habe aber ich habe
gekämpft mit den schwarzen Kacheln ich
habe keine Antworten bekommen es wurde
um viele Pausen gebeten und da hatte ich
dann wirklich Zeit mal
aktuell Lehre ich in hybrider Zeit in
Hybriden Format das heißt ich binde die
Teilnehmenden an die zu Hause sind
schwierig ist dann der Medienwechsel bei
Gruppenarbeiten und Präsentationen wird
es ebenfalls schwierig
ja aktuell mache ich Hybride Vorlesungen
aber nur noch im begründeten
Einzelfällen also wenn jemand nicht
teilnehmen kann dann muss er sich melden
und ich mache nur diese Ausnahmen das
heißt jemand der krank ist aber
eigentlich gesund also das heißt ich
verstoße nicht gegen die Fürsorgepflicht
wer Fieber hat darf nicht teilnehmen der
erkältet ist so wie ich heute den möchte
ich dass die Möglichkeit trotzdem geben
wenn jemand ja äh ein Unfall hatte
hatten wir auch Krücken der Raum ist
nicht barrierefrei frei und unter dem
Dach das wird schwierig darauf zu kommen
wenn jemand Urlaub hat auf Lehrgang oder
auf Zertifizierung ist dafür auch
virtuell teilnehmen wenn das mag und
wenn jemand ein krankes Kind zu Hause
hat schwanger ist ein Baby hat Kamera
aus wegen der Persönlichkeitsrechte ich
habe hier doch auch ein Format in rein
virtueller Form das ist ein hr-kolleg wo
ich Bachelor und Master
Abschlussarbeiten
betreue dass eine kleine Gruppe von 10
da funktioniert das virtuell super wir
kennen uns schon zwei drei Jahre diesen
sehr motiviert eine sehr gute Bachelor
Masterarbeit abzuschließen sich
auszutauschen mit den Studierenden das
passt wunderbar
ja Best Practice wie gehe ich vor wie
aktiviere ich das ist jetzt ein Beispiel
aus Wikipedia ein Foto das viele von
ihnen jetzt noch kennen ja das ist die
notwasserrinnung auf dem Hudson River
und meine Frage an die Studierenden ist
sie sind Pilot dieses Flugzeug sie
würden sie entscheiden flusslandung oder
Umkehr ich lehre auch bei den Piloten in
spe sie haben drei Minuten bis zur
Landung
kehren sie um oder wählen Sie den Fluss
entscheiden Sie sich ich mache was
manchmal auch mit MEDICOM Abfrage ja und
da hat sich dann das letzte Mal in
Studierender gemeldet und hat gesagt ich
würde immer den Fluss nehmen
und dann habe ich gefragt wieso würden
Sie immer den Fluss nehmen ja weil der
menschliche Schaden am geringsten wäre
bei einer flusslandung also sie erinnern
sich an die Concorde der der damals
hinter Concorde abgestürzt ist der hat
extra
ist lange oben geblieben um auf
umgewohnten Gebiet abzustürzen ne und
das ist so eine Erkenntnis auch für alle
anderen an an ethischer Kompetenz gar
nicht mehr zu überbieten wo es jedem
einem Schauer im Rücken runter läuft und
wo man weiß ja das ist Führung zu
entscheiden
am wenigsten wie kann ich entscheiden um
am wenigsten Menschen Leben zu gefährden
und den Wikipedia steht dass der
Flugkapitän zweimal durch dieses
sinkende also gewässerte Flugzeug lief
und ähm kontrolliert hat das wirklich
kein Passagier an Bord ist auch kein
Baby
zurückgeblieben ist das war im Januar
das war eiskalt das Wasser aber das ist
halt leadership der Kapitän geht als
Letzter von Bord ja das ist so eine
Aktivierung die ich anbiete und das
zweite den zweiten Tipp den ich mitgeben
darf ist Konflikte anzuzetteln warum wir
wollen in der Lehre zusammen ein
Spitzenteam werden ja wir lernen uns
kennen und dann ist es halt so dass die
Arbeitsmoral erstmal sinkt und dann sagt
tut man ja da müssen wir in den Konflikt
gehen und dann kommen wir zusammen in
Spitzenteam so das ist meine Philosophie
also wenn wir neu in der Gruppe sind
diskutieren wir das einmal aus und dann
ist gut und dann werden wir zum
Spitzenteam und dann kann es aber auch
sein dass wir wieder in einen Konflikt
zurückfallen aber wie gesagt das muss so
sein um das Beste aus allen
herauszuholen das dritte Praxisbeispiel
Praxisbeispiel dass ich dabei habe ist
ja die Gruppen von die Rollen von Welpen
die Rollen von Welpen die sagen es gibt
die erledigen die Denker und die
kommunizierer und man sollte in einer
Gruppe
sicherstellen in einer
Studierendengruppe dass alle dabei sind
das ist welche gibt die Macher die
darauf drängen jetzt machen wir weiter
Gruppenarbeit
was habt ihr für Ergebnisse die Denker
ja das heißt eben dass auch Inhalte
transportiert werden müssen dass das
wichtig ist dass die Sache auch ja
fundiert ist und zum Schluss die
kommunizierer die miteinander reden und
das ist eben wichtig auch gerade jetzt
in Gruppenarbeiten dass man die Gruppen
anleitet ja zu schauen dass sie alle
gruppenrollen mit dabei haben und zur
Not muss dann eben jemand die Rolle
wechseln und zu machen werden wenn sie
keiner in der Gruppe anmacher haben
sonst wird das nie fertig
ja Zusammenfassung meines lehr-lern
Settings das habe ich von Sieber dann
sehr bekanntes Buch zur Lehre und da
haben wir hier auf der einen Seite den
Lehrenden also mich mit meinem selbst
und meinem Fremdbild auf dem anderen die
Studierenden mit ihrem selbst und ihrem
Fremdbild ja und die Frage ist was macht
das für einen Sinn warum muss ich das
lernen was bringt das für nutzen den
muss ich transportieren es gibt ein
Leitbild das Leitbild der Bundeswehr wir
dienen Deutschland ja das prägt dann
natürlich auch die Studierenden es gibt
eine Erwartungshaltung natürlich möchte
jemand gute Noten eine Fähre Benotung
haben ja aber es ist halt wichtig wenn
man Führung lernt dass man den
Perspektivenwechsel wagt dass man sich
Feedback einhört dass ich auch lerne wie
gesagt das Beispiel mit dem Piloten
später gesagt hat ich würde immer den
Fluss wählen ja und die Qualität der
Lehre ist eben festzuhalten auch
im Rahmen der
ja der Evaluation die ich Ihnen
vorgestellt habe meine Resümee wenn du
wenn du eilig hast gehe langsam ich kann
soziale Kompetenz Entwicklung nicht
erzwingen ich kann sie nur entwickeln
und da bin ich total hartnäckig jeder
Studierende in meiner Vorlesung wird
mindestens fünfmal aufgerufen ob er sich
meldet oder nicht und muss sich
beteiligen darf sich beteiligen darf
auch sagen er möchte nicht sagen ist
auch gut aber er wird nicht desto trotz
trotzdem noch mal gefragt weil das ist
eben wichtig dass wir uns auch mit uns
und den anderen auseinandersetzen ich äh
das ist keine Kinoveranstaltung an der
Detail nehmen
ähm ich habe eine hohe Stoffvermittlung
aber die habe ich in Selbststudium
transferiert ich habe gesagt ich lehre
sie das was nicht im Buch steht und mir
ist der langfristige lernen Erfolg sehr
viel wichtiger als das bulina
ja ich nehme die Studierenden mit biete
Hybride Lehrer an den Sonderfällen
hundertprozentige Lösung gibt's nicht
lehren ist ein iterativer Prozess
Versuch und Irrtum drei und error ich
werde jedes Mal besser und ich freue
mich jetzt schon wieder auf meine
Studierenden ja danke schön dass Sie mir
zugehört haben ich freue mich auf Ihre
Fragen